l'information avait chuté mercredi soir
le pas de calais est bien le seul des
vingt départements surveillance
renforcée qui sera concerné par un
confinement lors des prochains week-ends
l'incident ci est en effet en
progression très rapide 23 % au cours
des sept derniers jours et dépasse je le
disais dorénavant le seuil des 4 100
pour cent mille habitants soit presque
deux fois la moyenne nationale
le niveau de saturation des services de
réanimation se situe au plus haut de
tous les départements français
pas de mise sous cloche partiel donc
pour l'ile-de-france où les
bouches-du-rhône où les élus locaux
s'étaient opposés à cette mesure
dans le même temps trois nouveaux
départements rejoignent la liste des
territoires placé en surveillance
renforcée len l'aube ainsi que les
hautes-alpes
autre mesure annoncée pour enrayer
l'épidémie dans les départements
surveillance renforcée le port du masque
deviendra obligatoire en extérieur dans
l'ensemble des zones urbaines les
centres commerciaux non alimentaires de
plus de 10 mille mètres carrés devront
quant à eux fermés leurs portes
de plus jean castex a encouragé
préfecture et municipalités à prendre
des mesures au sujet des manifestations
et des espaces extérieurs à forte
fréquentation
les préfets seront également invités en
concertation bien sûr avec les maires
concernés à interdire ou à réglementer
l'accès de certains sites très
fréquentés pendant les week-ends les
préfets pourront être amené à interdire
les manifestations organisées dans
l'espace public notamment pendant les
week-ends
lorsqu'elles présenteront un risque
sanitaire avéré au regard de leurs
conditions d'organisation
l'ensemble des mesures sont effectives
dès ce vendredi sur le plan vaccinal le
gouvernement a prévu d'accélérer le
rythme des injections dans les prochains
mois l'exécutif se fixe l'objectif d'au
moins 20 millions de personnes vaccinées
à la mi mai
grâce notamment à l'arrivée en france du
vaccin astrazeneca
de plus il sera possible de se faire
vacciner dans les pharmacies dès la
semaine du 15 mars
la haute autorité de santé a donné son
approbation et le décret autorisant
cette nouvelle étape majeure dans notre
stratégie de vaccination sortira demain
la vaccination se passera comme pour la
grippe vous n'aurez pas besoin d'une
prescription médicale et vous pourrez
vous rendre directement à n'officie
malgré l'accélération prévu des
vaccinations le gouvernement prévient
que les prochaines semaines seront un
minima tout aussi compliquée que les
précédentes
jean castex a exclu tout assouplissement
des mesures même territorialisée sans
amélioration globale de la situation